So how's everybody doing?
Good conference so far, learning everything?
All right, so if you've never heard me before,
my name is Dr. Kevin Codders.
I practice in Minnesota, headspot accent but people
could have a Norwegian accent up here, don't they?
A little bit.
So if I say you're a batchah, or anything like that, you know,
Why?
I see mainly cancer in Lyme patients.
Some really sick autoimmune patients.
I have a pretty good website.
If you haven't been on our website,
probably have at least 100 videos on our website.
I like to teach.
So hopefully I can make this really boring subject
exciting today.
I'm open to teaching whatever you want to learn about.
So we're going to open up to some questions.
And if you have specific questions to what I'm talking about,
feel free to ask them.
But I might not be able to get to everybody.
So we're going to be talking about some hidden causes of disease.
And we're going to be talking about genetics.
Doesn't that sound fun?
Yes.
So your DNA as a hidden cause of disease.
All right, are you ready?
I was really nervous.
I told my staff, and I got about 60 slides.
And it's going to be all of genetics.
I'm just spreading it aboard everybody to tears.
So I see there's only a few open seats
by the time I'm done.
It'll probably be half empty.
So I'm going to apologize right up front.
So I really like looking at people's genes.
And after I talk, I hopefully you'll go,
wow, I want to look at my genes too,
because it can make a big difference in getting a person better.
Most of my patients that come to me
are in a situation where they're either really sick.
Stage four cancer.
That's about 80% of our cancer patients come in at stage four.
They've tried chemotherapy.
They've tried radiation.
They've done surgery.
And they've been given a timeline, most of them.
And I'm not a healer.
I believe I'm just a doctor, which I believe my responsibility
is to pray for wisdom constantly.
And then to walk in that wisdom is best I can.
And just be in one of the things
when I pray for wisdom for myself
is that God always drives me to study.
So when we talk about genetics,
I have some cup gene defects that you'll see a little later.
So I have a little OCD with my study.
And I have no other life, but that's the way it is.
But I like it.
So why don't we go out of vacation?
And my wife says, OK, lay down and rest for a little bit.
That lasts for about five minutes.
Then I have to get up and read a book.
So that's just the way God wired me.
So when I see patients that have gone everywhere else
and can't get better, boy, that's a heavy responsibility.
And to me, that is a responsibility.
So when God sends us a patient, I believe
that in a certain sense, I've got to figure this out.
And so I'm always searching for other missing pieces
in the puzzle.
So when we talk about genetics,
I think this is a big missing piece of the puzzle
in a lot of people's cases.
They've gone to functional medicine doctors.
They've gone to good functional chiropractors
and naturopaths.
And they've done adrenal work and thyroid work
and all this different kind of stuff.
But there's something that they're missing.
So I've spoken at other life conferences
and talked about immunology.
That's another big missing piece of the puzzle
that I believe that most doctors don't understand.
We're not going to be able to talk about that at this time.
We don't have the time.
But go on our website if you have a Lyme disease.
I have a lot of really good videos on what I believe
that there's three stages of Lyme, not just two,
that will help you understand that.
Also, I have books out there.
I think I only have the cancer books left.
But please know on our website, all my books
are downloadable free.
So you can get my books for free on our website?
Yes.
What's our website?
Right there.
www.connersclinic.com.
So I give all our information for free.
So this video that's going to be made here, I'll get it.
And I'll actually put Snips in but I put our website too.
Because I really believe that an educated person
can take responsibility for their own disease
and can make better decisions.
So I do not want to be in a co-dependent relationship
with my patients.
I don't want them to depend upon me.
I want to educate them as much as I can
so that they can make their own decisions.
So I try to put all the information up on our website.
So I think you can spend about two weeks on my website
just watching things.
It probably kill you, the boredom, but you could do that.
So when we talk about genetics, we want
to look at your genes.
So how do we look at somebody's genes?
So there is a real nice test out right now.
If anybody who's had this done, it's called the 23andMe.
Has anybody run their 23andMe test?
Not just a few people.
After today, there'll probably be a whole bunch more people
ready than if I do a good job.
Don't understand?
I don't make any money if you run the 23andMe test.
You go to 23andMe.com and there's instructions on our website.
So on my website, I have tabs across the top.
And there's a tab that says genetic testing.
I actually have a video under that tab
telling you how to go to 23andMe in order your genetic test.
So 23andMe is simply a lab.
They'll send you a kit.
You have a, it's a saliva sample.
You can do it at home.
They have excellent instructions.
You register your kit.
You spin in this tube.
You send it back to them.
And they'll send you an email saying,
thank you, we got your kit.
We'll let you know when your test comes back in.
When you get the results back from them,
they'll give you all this nice fluffy data
that you're 12% dramatic and 6% Norwegian.
I didn't know I had any French in me,
but this is, I don't care about any of that stuff.
So what we need to see is your raw data.
So we take, I mean, I take your raw data
and look at that and put it in a program.
And that's what we're going to be talking about today.
You won't be able to see any of this information
that I'm talking to you about from your 23 and me,
yourself as a lay person.
You have to go to a doctor that's
going to extrapolate the raw data.
So that's what we're going to be talking about.
Is that help?
All right.
So that's how we look at your genetics.
Last time I was here, I believe we talked a little bit
about gut health.
And the genetics tell us a bigger story about your gut.
So our software that we put your gene profile in,
and remember, genetics, your 23 and me
is running thousands and different genes,
takes those genes and separates them
in the components that affect different parts of your body.
So the first section that we talk about when we look at your genes
is the health of your gut.
So is the health of your gut really important?
Yes.
Then I understand I see a lot of cancer and lying patients.
And many times they'll ask that question,
what does my gut have to do with my breast cancer?
I don't have any digestive problems.
What does this have to do with anything?
And my answer back is really the health of your gut.
You can argue that any diseases,
the benefit you could probably argue that most diseases
can begin with the gut.
So by the gut, we're talking about your stomach
and your intestinal tract.
So we really do need to look at the gut.
And there's some genetic pictures that help us look at the gut.
So our first section when we look at your 23 and me profile,
when we look at your genetic profile
are those genes that affect your gut.
Now understand, when we look at your genes,
these are your genes.
You were born with them.
They're not going to change, typically.
So when we run another 23 and me profile in a year
to see if your genes change because they won't change.
So you get your genes, what a leal from your mother
and what a leal from your father.
And then that is what you have inherited.
Now there is what are called epigenetic defects.
An epigenetic defect can be a defect in a gene
due to environmental influences.
An epigenetic defect, you're actually taking notes.
So an epigenetic defect is a defect that happens
because of environmental influences.
I work in an abutation plant.
Today I'm working with mercury and aluminum all day long.
It can affect my genes.
So I could have a defect on my genes
because of environmental influence.
I worked in Chernobyl for a year, measuring radiation,
and it affected my genes.
Follow me?
So I once had a patient who was from Russia.
And her gene profile, she actually did not have cancer.
But her gene profile was the worst I've ever seen.
And I said, oh, I want to do a study on you
because this is really interesting.
This is the worst I've ever seen.
She had more double leal defects, mediated
a defect from both parents than I've ever seen.
I said, what was your history?
She had been in the United States for 30 years
or something like that.
Well, her father actually had cancer twice
and her father was the head of an agricultural,
big, giant industrial farm in Russia.
And his whole responsibility was mixing the chemicals.
So I said, oh, my gosh, I would just love her father.
I believe was deceased and her grandparents were deceased.
But I would have loved to see a genetic profile
on her grandparents that lived prior to this exposure.
And then her father and her siblings as a study.
Now, understand this availability of these gene profiles
has only been in the last few years.
So we don't have necessarily that ability.
And her parents are now deceased,
but it would have been really interesting.
I want to put money on her grandparents
not having those same gene defects.
So in a sense, chemical exposure, radiation exposure, et cetera,
that's affecting our genes, including medications,
vaccinations, et cetera.
We are damaging our gene pool as a species.
It's pretty sad.
Especially when you look at as many gene profiles
that I do, it's like, oh, man.
So there are some of these genes that we're going to look at.
That you can have an influence on nutritionally,
especially the ones when we're talking about the gut.
There's much nutritional influence that you could have on these.
Some of you could use specific nutrients
that can help push those gene pathways that have defects on it.
And some are dietary, some are lifestyle changes,
some are easier to affect than others.
Some are not very easy to affect at all.
And that's what makes it sad.
So unfortunately, we live in a fallen world,
and there's more chemicals that we're exposed to on a daily basis,
even if you're trying to eat organic and do everything right.
But the fact exists that you're still
exposed to just enormous amount of stuff
no matter how hard you're trying to be healthy.
So the first genes that we look at from a dietary standpoint
are these HLA genes.
So this is kind of, that's a little snippet, that little clip,
is a clip from my software.
So a patient would receive a whole giant printout
of about 30-some pages that we would look at.
And it's very daunting, really, from a patient perspective.
So I try to explain it.
And understand I require all my patients
if we're going to go through a genetic profile
to watch my videos under the genetic tab, which
is a little daunting to itself.
But if you watch it a few times, I'm not
trying to say that you have to be knowledgeable in all this.
But it's almost like we're speaking a little different language.
So the more you can know, I think the better
you can understand why I'm making recommendations.
So these first HLA genes are genes
that affect gluten sensitivity.
So when you look at this profile, like you're
going to see a whole bunch of these nips,
if you stay with me for these few hours,
it has the gene there, the HLA-DQA1.
And then the gene name, after it, you see the top one
on there.
And then there's a blank.
Because this particular individual who I patent
pasted this off of does not have a defect there.
So you want to have a blank here.
My pointer work.
Oh, it doesn't work on a screen, OK?
So you want to have a blank after where it says,
in the column, a variant.
I use the term defect.
That's because I'm used to using that.
A better term would be variant, because some of these variants
can be actually beneficial to have.
Most of them aren't.
So that person does not have a variant in that particular gene.
These are the known genes that affect gluten sensitivity.
Now, I think somebody's going to be talking about gluten
sensitivity in a little bit.
So I'll leave this alone.
But when I see a genetic profile like this,
and the person has a double allele defect in that bottom one,
do you see that?
So they have a two there.
So they inherited a gene from their mother
and from their father.
And a single allele defect in that middle one, do you see that?
So as you're going to see some other categories of genes
that we're going to talk about, when this particular individual
has a smothering of defects throughout all the genes,
I would say this isn't all that bad.
But when a person has any defects in this,
I would say you shouldn't be eating gluten
from a genetic standpoint.
So everything we're going to be talking about today,
and if we do a gene profile of you, we're only talking
about your genes.
So there are other reasons why a person should change their diet.
So a person can have no defects in their HLA genes for gluten
and yet still have gluten sensitivity.
Because gluten sensitivity has to do with an immune reaction
to the peptides of the protein, glianin,
and it really has much less to do with a genetic predisposition.
Follow me?
But that's a lecture in itself.
And I'll save that for another person.
So the MCM6 gene has to do with lactose intolerance.
Now, I don't usually take people off of dairy
because of lactose anyhow.
We take people off of dairy because of the protein and dairy
case seed, and they have a sensitivity to that
because they have an immune sensitivity to it.
We're not really looking at the genes.
So really, when I look at a person's gene profile,
we pretty much ignore this first piece,
except it does give me some gravity to push them
to what I already tell most people to go out of gluten-free diet
anyhow.
Because inflammation in the gut equals inflammation in the brain.
And inflammation in the brain equals problems
to the rest of the body.
So if you're not already gluten-free,
and we're going to have a lunch here in a little while,
it's probably going to be bread.
I believe I fall into the category that I think everybody
should be gluten-free because it's highly inflammatory
to your gut.
And when you have inflammation in the gut,
you have inflammation in the brain.
So we'll move on.
This also tests for PETA allergy genes.
Now, I don't see people particularly for allergies anymore.
I see mainly cancer in my patients.
And even this person doesn't have a known PETA allergy,
but she has two defects, single-liol defects,
in both the PETA allergy genes.
Now, also, if you're fairly compromised,
health-wise, you probably shouldn't be eating PETA's any home
because they have a lot of mycotoxins involved.
Nobody should really be eating a lot of PETA's, right?
But certainly, if you have the defects,
you should not be eating PETA's, OK?
Still with me?
All right.
So there are some genes for caffeine consumption,
and how well you detoxify caffeine.
That's the last one, that caffeine metabolism.
This person has a double-liol defect.
In this particular case, this variant actually
helps you detoxify metabolized caffeine much quicker.
Before we had the gene profile, I'd
say, is caffeine good for you or bad for you?
Well, does caffeine make you have to go to the bathroom?
Yeah, I drink about three cups of coffee,
and I run and I have to go urinate.
Well, then you have the gene that metabolizes caffeine
very quickly, and caffeine isn't necessarily bad for you.
No, I could drink a whole pot of coffee,
and it doesn't make me go to the bathroom.
Well, then you shouldn't be drinking coffee, OK?
But now we could look at the genetic picture and say,
should you be drinking coffee or shouldn't be drinking coffee?
And this person would be fine drinking a little coffee.
But if you had a blade there, then you probably shouldn't
be drinking very much coffee.
Follow me?
But that's just kind of a fun one.
That's not what we're dealing with real health or not.
Now, we start to get into real sickness.
Your FUT2 genes actually know in the new gene profiles.
Now, understand the software that we use
we're constantly adding new genes as discoveries are made.
Because this is literally a new science.
So new researchers coming out literally daily
on what the different genes do.
So we did this human genome project.
In America, they gathered all this information
of all the different genes, and they
realized that there's a whole lot less than they thought there
was, and now they're trying to figure out
what these different genes do.
The FUT2 genes responsibility is very important
when it comes to your gut.
Because your gut health has to do
with a number of different things.
The cells of the intestinal tract have
to be tightly packed together.
That's how they are when you're bored.
And they only allow things through that you have receptors for,
or that are small enough that can
sneak through between the cells.
So if we have a healthy cell membrane, a healthy cell wall,
a healthy cells of the intestinal tract,
then we're going to have a healthier disposition overall.
However, there's all sorts of things that damage our gut.
So there's genetically modified foods that damage our gut.
There's inflammatory things that damage our gut.
Medications, chemicals, yada, yada, yada.
There's a zillion things that damage our gut.
What do we have a damaged gut?
I said, that could equal a damaged body.
Because remember, I've said in past,
you are what you absorb, right?
So you aren't just what you eat.
You are what you absorb.
Let's use an example.
Well, I'm not supposed to eat a lot of fish from Michigan
because it has mercury in it.
So I better not, you know, I'm limited to the amount of fish.
Actually, do you have absorption sites in your gut for mercury?
No.
But do you probably have a damaged gut
that mercury is going to be able to leak through
and get into your bloodstream?
Yes.
So if you had a perfectly healthy gut,
eating some mercury in your fish shouldn't bother you.
You should expel it into the toilet.
However, when I have a damaged gut membrane
and my epithelial cells of my gut are spread apart,
all things get through that works,
a lot of things get through that we're supposed to get through.
That I make myself toxic and I make myself inflamed
because my immune system responds to these things
that never should have been in my bloodstream
in the first place and my immune system goes,
what in the heck is that?
Let's kill it.
And it fires an inflammatory response.
When there are food particles, peptides of gluten
and other things and heavy metals and toxins
and things like that, those things don't die.
When your immune system tries to kill it
and all you do is have this systemic inflammatory process
going on.
Follow me.
Health of the gut equals health of the body.
When you have inflammation of the gut,
you also have inflammation in the brain.
So it's really important to have a healthy gut.
Your FUT2 genes, now there's only three listed here.
Now in our new reports, I think there's 20.
These are responsible for making an enzyme
that makes the healthy bucosolayer
that lines the intestinal tract.
So the bucosolayer that lines the intestinal tract,
you can think of as the apartment building
for your microbiota to live.
So your microbiota or your normal flora,
the good bacteria that lives symbiotically in your gut
that help kill off pathogens that help keep a balance.
You guys still with me?
Okay.
So if I have FUT2 gene defects like this poor person right here,
double allele defects in all three of them,
they do not have the carpenters to make a healthy
apartment building for the microbiota to live for birth.
So even let's pretend, give this person
the best case scenario.
They had a mother who did not take drugs,
did not ever take antibiotics,
inherited through the mother's breast bell,
a wonderful microbiota.
That normal healthy floral layer.
So they have a perfect microbiota.
The mom did not give her antibiotics at all
during her early years, which would destroy the microbiota.
Let's pretend they have a perfect microbiota,
but they have these FUT2 gene defects
so they don't make a really healthy bucosolayer.
And now they get live at 23 years old
and they go on a doctor's cycling for early life,
which really live won't be the right thing to do.
But it also wipes out the healthy microbiota that they had.
And now having FUT2 gene defects,
it's very hard to get that back.
So the people that we see with FUT2 gene defects
have a very difficult time
chronic with chronic health conditions
because they have a very difficult time
keeping a healthy microbiota.
Yes.
So what do we suggest?
You're getting the head of us.
So this is very important, these FUT2 genes
are really super important.
And with the patient base that I see,
we see people that have a lot of defects here.
Not all of them have double defects in all of them.
This person is really having a difficult time.
So then you go back to last year's right symposium
to learn how to heal the gut.
So how do you heal the gut?
You have to use specific nutrition
that's gonna heal the gut.
You have to use prebiotics as well as probiotics.
So most people they go, oh, I got a bad gut.
So I'm gonna take some probiotics.
And it just doesn't seem to make my gut better.
You understand this person right here
with this gene defect might not have any, quote, unquote,
gut symptoms.
So that's the beauty of looking at labs
is that you bypass the person's symptomatology.
So they might not have any symptoms,
but they still have issues that we need to address.
This person with a gene defect like this,
how would you treat it?
They need to be on some gut nutrition.
They need to be on a prebiotic.
They need to be educated on what prebiotics
are in their normal diet.
And they need to be on a probiotic.
Possibly doing probiotic intubus, retention intubus as well.
We need to heal their microbiota.
So there's multiple avenues in this
and we have a bunch of videos on this other website.
Because we're doing this with all our patients.
Your question over there first, does that answer it?
Perfect.
Yes.
Can you get enough prebiotic fiber from your diet?
No, normally you can.
If you're eating good, you're eating some green bananas,
you're eating some raw onion family foods,
you're eating some raw dandelion leaves,
you're eating some chicory substances, things like that.
Those are all good prebiotics.
If a person has a lot of FUT2G defects,
I think they should supplement.
We use a product that I developed called Sun Spectrum
and has a modified guar gum that statistically
from all the research is the best prebiotic on the market.
But again, a prebiotic is simply feeding,
helping to feed those epithelial cells.
If you continue to have inflammatory processes going out
of the gut like you continue to eat poorly,
you continue to eat genetically modified foods
and you've gluten all these inflammatory things
even though they only don't cause any problems,
quote unquote, they are.
So then it's a losing battle.
So you do have to make those changes as well.
Yes.
Is a fermented food prebiotic?
No.
So fermented food has probiotics,
but you're going to see it a little bit.
If you have specific gene defects,
you've got to be very careful with those.
And if you're going to use a fermented food,
fermented foods are a phenomenal source of probiotics.
I always tell my patients that just a couple of table spoons
of raw sauerkraut has more probiotics
than your entire bottle of probiotics does.
However, you have to be careful with fermented foods
because it contains a lot of histamine.
But if you have ABP1 gene defects that we're going to see
in a second or HNMT gene defects,
you can't use fermented foods.
Is that help?
So this person needs some support of their gut.
Still with me?
Yes.
A flora.
Is that the prebiotic?
So the flora is the old term that's used
that is now we call the microbiota.
So I don't know what you mean by flora.
So they're probably, she said you should use something
for two weeks before starting your probiotics.
They're probably speaking of a prebiotic.
That's probably what they were speaking of.
I think you can do it concurrently.
I don't think there's a problem with that.
So we put people out of product that uses it concurrently.
These are your ABP1 genes.
The ABP1 genes that affect histamine.
So histamine is an inflammatory product
that your body normally makes.
But it's a chemical that's in a lot of different foods as well.
The ABP1 genes are the genes that make the DAO enzyme
that breaks down histamine in your gut
and partly in your blood.
Very, very important gene.
Because this tells us whether the person
can use fermented foods.
And by the way, cyanodon fermented foods,
if you have a lot of leaky gut issues,
you can't use fermented foods right away either.
Because they'll cross the gut in larger,
the larger molecules will cross the gut border
and cause inflammation in the blood of the tissues.
So you've got to do some work on healing the gut
many times, not all the time,
before you can start using fermented foods.
So if a person has these gene defects
and this person has double allele defect on one,
I would be careful with this person using fermented foods.
So your ABP1 genes are really important.
In a matter of fact, people with ABP1 gene defects
and then this next family, this HNMTG defects,
this can be this right here,
the first part of the report,
can be the main cause of the person's symptom problems
right here.
So HNMTG, these genes,
get rid of histamine in the tissue.
Now again, you normally produce histamine.
Histamine is an immune chemical
that's produced in the presence of an antigen
or an allergen in your body.
And it has a purpose, a very good purpose,
but it's supposed to have a very short half-life.
Why?
Because the HNMT genes are making enzyme
that break it down to get rid of it,
so that it's out of your body.
It does its job and it's out of your body.
Now remember, almost everything that we're going to talk about here,
everything in your body is about malice.
It's all about malice.
There's not necessarily good guys and bad guys, right?
Bad guys are only bad guys when they're out of malice.
The good guys can be bad guys when they're out of malice.
I'm going to take a bunch of antioxidants
because I don't want any oxidation of my body.
Well, then you're good enough. I have cancer.
Okay?
You have to have some oxidants and free radicals in your body
because that's when it kills pathogens and cancer cells.
But when you have too many, they can cause cancer.
Follow?
It's all about malice.
So just when, if I give a patient here I want to take three of these a day,
they go, well, I'm going to take ten because that would be better
because we're Americans.
That can be bad.
So it's all about malice.
Yes?
I'm just wondering if your variants there are,
in other words, not tonight, polymorphism.
So good question.
Do we know that these variants are truly problematic?
Just by looking at the gene profile, we do not.
So there's other things that we can look at that.
I was going to put in the slide presentation too,
but I thought, I don't want to bore you to death.
I would literally kill you.
There's some other tests that we can run at organics tests
that we can actually look at histamine levels.
The only problem with those, the genetic test doesn't change.
The organic test changes rapidly because it's your current,
a stepped photograph of your body chemistry that can be different right now
compared to three hours from now.
So that's the only barrier to there.
Just one thought, I ran my MTHR, MTHFRS.org.com,
and I thought, oh, I've got G6PD because I've got two double mutations.
I looked them up, and they're just normal.
And I had polymorphisms that mean nothing.
So I don't have G6PD, and I did the quantitative test.
But I'm just wondering if you see these coupled things,
and you think, oh, it's bad, but it's just a normal polymorphism.
Sure, you can do your O test to verify,
but I just wondered if you know for each of those genes
that they are denying silence.
So we say, would a person have G defects?
Does that mean they're doomed?
Does that mean that's causing a symptom pattern in their body?
I'm more asking, let's say you take the time line,
and if there's a defect in there, could it be that that doesn't affect the HNMT anyway?
Okay, so with our 20 seconds we have left, remember one thing.
That defect in that gene does not mean that that gene is not working completely.
And we don't even know that that, just because there's research on the EMTHFR677 gene
that we'll talk about later, that a double allele defect decreases its function by 65%.
That's on average.
And even at that, it's still working.
So it doesn't mean you're doomed to that disease or you're doomed to a problem with that.
It just means that we do have compromise in there, especially with the greater amount of defects in a family.
That's all we can really say.
And so the environment trumps everything.
So if your environment is good, then you're going to have less problems with that gene profile.
Now, again, if a person's coming to me, typically they have symptoms.
So then we want to clarify their genetics with their symptoms and really get a better picture on what we want to support.
Is that help?
So there's no guarantee that just because I have defects, then I'm going to absolutely have problems.
But there's also no guarantee if I have zero defects, then I'm not going to have a whole host of problems.
Because I, just because I don't, let's say this person is actually really, really good, actually.
But I have had people with single and double allele defects almost every one of those.
The chance of that person having histamine-clearing problems is like through the roof.
Does that make sense?
So you want to address it.